SEASONED FIGHTERS FROM SYRIA.
OKAY, WE'RE GOING TO HAVE MORE
ON THAT.
WE'RE LIVE TONIGHT ACROSS
UKRAINE.
I WANT TO BEGIN WITH MATTHEW
CHANCE IN THE CAPITAL OF KYIV.
MATTHEW, WHAT IS THE LATEST
GROUND WHERE YOU ARE TONIGHT,
WHERE OF COURSE ZELENSKYY
ACTUALLY WENT TO HIS OFFICE,
RIGHT, AND PUT THAT STATEMENT
OUT FROM THE OFFICE, NOT FROM
THE BUNKER, TO PUTIN DIRECTLY.
>> Reporter: YES, HE DID.
IT JUST SHOWS YOU HOW DEFIANT
THE UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT
CONTINUES TO BE IN THE FACE OF
THIS ONGOING RUSSIAN PRESSURE.
AND THAT PRESSURE HAS BEEN
RATCHETED UP A GREAT DEAL WITH
MORE MILITARY MANEUVERS,
MILITARY ADVANCES, RATHER, ON
THE PART OF THE RUSSIANS AROUND
THE UKRAINIAN CAPITAL.
BUT, YOU KNOW, THAT'S NOT
LEADING TO HIM BACKING DOWN.
LOOK, THERE'S BEEN SOME HOPEFUL,
I SUPPOSE, SIGNS AS WELL WITHIN
THE PAST HOUR OR SO WITH THE
RUSSIANS SAYING THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO ENACT A CEASE-FIRE FOR
10:00 IN THE MORNING LOCAL TIME
IN A NUMBER OF CITIES INCLUDING
KYIV, BUT ALSO KHARKIV,
MARIUPOL, ALL OF THESE PLACES
WHERE THERE'S BEEN FIERCE
FIGHTING OVER THE PAST COUPLE OF
DAYS.
NOT JUST FIERCE FIGHTING BETWEEN
THE ARMIES, BUT FIERCE ATTACKS
ON THE RESIDENTIAL AND THE
CIVILIAN AREAS AS WELL.
I WENT TO AN AREA EARLIER ON
TODAY TO THE SOUTH OF THE
UKRAINIAN CAPITAL, WHICH HAS
ALSO SUFFERED A HEAVY TOLL AS A
RESULT OF THE TANKS ON ITS
RESIDENTIAL QUARTERS.
TAKE A LOOK.
CLEARING UP THE BROKEN DEBRIS OF
A SHATTERED HOME.
THIS IS THE DEVASTATION CAUSED
BY A RUSSIAN ATTACK ON A
RESIDENTIAL NEIGHBORHOOD IN A
SMALL UKRAINIAN TOWN.
50 MILES SOUTH OF THE UKRAINIAN
CAPITAL IS NOWHERE NEAR THE
FRONT LINES.
BUT IT HAS FELT THE RAGE AND THE
PAIN OF THIS WAR.
WE'VE COME INSIDE ONE OF THE
HOUSES THAT WAS AFFECTED BY WHAT
WAS APPARENTLY RANDOM ARTILLERY
OR ROCKET FIRE INTO THIS
RESIDENTIAL NEIGHBORHOOD.
YOU CAN SEE JUST HOW SHATTERED
THE LIVES OF THE FAMILY HERE
WERE.
LOOK.
THE WINDOWS HAVE ALL BEEN BLOWN
OUT OBVIOUSLY.
ALL THEIR BELONGINGS HAVE BEEN
LEFT BEHIND AS THEY HAVE GONE
INTO HIDING.
THERE'S A PICTURE UP THERE OF
WHAT SEEMS TO BE SOME OF THE
PEOPLE WHO LIVED HERE.
IT WAS A FAMILY WITH SOME
CHILDREN.
APPARENTLY THEY HAVE SURVIVED
THIS, WHICH IS GOOD.
BUT OF COURSE WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE SITUATION AND THE WAY THE
RUSSIANS HAVE BEEN SHELLING
RESIDENTIAL AREAS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY, SO MANY PEOPLE HAVEN'T
SURVIVED.
THIS IS INTERESTING, COME HAVE A
LOOK.
IT'S THE CHILDREN'S BEDROOM.
YOU CAN SEE OVER HERE, LOOK, THE
BUNK BEDS, THE ROOF THAT'S
FALLEN DOWN ONTO THE TOP OF THEM
WHEN THAT SHELL HIT.
AND OF COURSE IN THE EVACUATION,
THE KIDS HAVE LEFT ALL THEIR
TOYS UP HERE.
IT JUST SHOWS YOU THAT NO MATTER
WHERE YOU ARE IN THIS COUNTRY
WITH RUSSIA ATTACKING, TANKS AND
CITIES ACROSS IT, LIVES HAVE
BEEN SHATTERED.
STANISLAV IS A CLOSE FRIEND OF
THE FAMILY WHO WERE NEARLY
KILLED IN THEIR KIDS HERE,
GODFATHER TO THE THREE CHILDREN
WHO ESCAPED WITH THEIR LIVES.
NOW HE HAS ONE REQUEST, HE TELLS
ME, FOR THE UNITED STATES.
PLEASE, CLOSE THE SKIES OVER
UKRAINE, HE BEGS.
IF WE CAN JUST CONTACT NATO AND
ASK THEM THIS, EVERYTHING WILL
BE FINE.
OTHERWISE, HE WARNS, PUTIN WILL
CROSS UKRAINE AND THREATEN THE
WHOLE OF EUROPE.
IN A BUNKER UNDER THE TOWN, ITS
TERRIFIED CHILDREN SINGING
UKRAINE'S NATIONAL ANTHEM THAT
KEEPS THEM CALM AS RUSSIA
INVADES A WHOLE GENERATION OF
UKRAINIANS IS BEING UNITED BY
THIS WAR, TOGETHER, AS THEY
SHELTER FROM THE HORRORS ABOVE.
ERIN, IT'S ALSO BEEN CONFIRMED
TONIGHT THAT THE UKRAINIAN AND
THE RUSSIAN FOREIGN MINISTERS
WILL MEET FACE-TO-FACE IN